India's government disabling a
controversial finance bill in Parliament
ahead of a budget next week it wants to
increase taxes but many people say
they're already struggling to make ends
meets Catherine Sawyer reports
these restaurants staff in Nairobi are
worried the government is proposing to
increase income tax by five percent for
those earning more than five thousand
dollars a month it will also introduce a
mandatory contribution to a housing fund
three percent will be deducted from an
employee's salary and marched by the
employer
business owners like obado obado who
owns this Cafe says it's a disaster our
employees first of all right now as we
speak are already very constrained so we
are going to have to cut down on the
number of stuff and Cafe daily it has
about 130 staff right now we have looked
at how many staff we have and we think
that we may have to go between 10 to 15
percent of the staff we're going to go
down
so that's about 20 stuff and that's a
huge huge impact
some Canyons have taken to the streets
to express their anger the
demonstrations are often broken up by
police
President William Ruto and other
government officials have publicly
threatened members of parliament who do
not vote for the Bill I'm a better
worded person because a senator has gone
to court to block it he says there are
other ways to raise revenue very many
aspects of the bill will let clear
provisions of the Constitution
on property rights on the road of the
Senate on the Mandate of Parliament
so a lot of things are being undermined
by introducing the housing Levy the
government wants to build more
affordable houses than sell to Canyons
at a reduced mortgage rate they will be
vetted and those who do not qualify will
be given a refund after seven years some
say they are skeptical it's not a
priority it has come
it has come to steal from Kenyans and
that's why it must be resisted
the new Administration wants about 25
billion dollars to fund its budget
balance its finances and service a huge
external debt Parliament will either
pass the bill as it is rejected or amend
sections of it many Kenyans say they are
struggling as it is and they cannot
afford to pay more taxes
the employees are on edge to them taking
away money from their already low pay
means more suffering and perhaps job
losses Catherine zoy Al Jazeera Nairobi